Chris asks would you rather invest in a
high-growth hiber and startup or a
moderate growth minimal burn startup
assuming they had similar business
models and markets how would you advise
each company if they were both in your
accelerator great question I'm actually
ok with both situations
I like the founder to do what they're
comfortable with so they can go to work
every day and be highly productive and I
trust the captain
I trust the person in the driver seat I
don't want to be a backseat driver if
the person who's flying the plane feels
that they can go up to you know thirty
four thousand feet and there's less
turbulence there and then they got some
clean air and they want to you know
punch it and go a little faster great if
they feel like hey you know what they
want to stay at 32,000 feet and they
want to go a little slower and they feel
more in control of the plane I'm fine
with that too why wouldn't I be
what I'm looking for is a company that
gets to fifty to a hundred million
dollars in revenue as a baseline and I'm
looking for a company that can return
fifty to a hundred times the money we
invest in it so typically when we invest
in a company you know we're investing at
a two million dollar valuation or so
when they come to our accelerator a six
to ten million dollar valuation when
they graduate the accelerator may be a
ten to 20 million dollar accelerator
when they're doing some seed round
before they get their Series A and a
series a stupid way 12 to 25 million
these days so we really don't care about
that that's not what's important to us I
think I would lean towards the
high-growth one because that's a sign of
somebody who aggressively wants to win
but if they were doing it in a stupid
non considered way then I would not feel
good about it so somebody who wants to
drive a hundred miles an hour on a windy
road with the headlights turned off no
but if they want to punch it and in this
analogy you know go a little bit faster
than the speed limit on a straightaway
I'm all for it not in real life don't
speed don't turn the headlights off but
in the startup world I like a little
speed I like a little velocity I think
speed wins in a lot of cases
but you don't ever want to go so fast
that you start feeling the car wobble
right you ever get that feeling the car
starts shaking you going a little too
fast or maybe hear a tire screech a
little bit on a turn or an exit ramp
bring it down bring it down a little bit
ok some aren't great question